netflix has been putting out original
programming for almost six years so
it'll come as no surprise to find
they've gotten pretty good at it from
thrilling adventure flicks to sci-fi
spectacles these are the best netflix
originals in 2021 so far
the rise of the gig economy has changed
the way people get ahead in the world
and the white tiger plays with this idea
in a masterful way the film focuses on a
young man named balram who grows up in
india and decides at a young age that
he's destined for greatness however
india's rigid class system has other
things in store for him while rom tries
to get ahead as best he can with the
situation he's put in working as a
driver for a wealthy family however
opportunities are few and far between
and balram has to do some pretty awful
things in order to achieve what he
believes is his destiny lead actor adash
gorov is so charismatic and the white
tiger is shot so beautifully that it's
easy to get caught up in the film's
world making the horrific nature of its
third act even more shocking the white
tiger has been noted for its
similarities to the oscar-winning
classic parasite and like that movie it
defies any kind of genre tagging with a
killer cast great script and near
faultless direction this is a compelling
under the radar watch
it's easy to dismiss finding ohana as a
retread of a movie you've seen a dozen
times before a ragtag group of kids band
together to discover a set of clues find
some hidden treasure and of course learn
more about themselves along the way it's
the goonies it's holes it's stranger
things but finding ohana stands out from
these stories in some very distinct ways
for one the movie is well aware that the
audience knows this song already finding
ohana has been praised by some critics
for wasting no time on its first act and
instead setting up higher stakes once
the protagonists start hunting for
treasure even more impressive is the
beautiful backdrop of hawaiian scenery
and culture finding ohana does a great
job of showcasing its breathtaking
vistas and unique cultural components to
make the whole film feel new and
exciting finding ohana is a
family-friendly adventure with just
enough nostalgia and beauty to keep
adults invested alongside a heap of
adventure and goofiness to win over the
kids
that smells like the butthole the hell
unless you happen to live in the british
countryside it's likely that you could
do with a little more scenery like this
in your life throw on a fascinating
period piece and a few fantastic actors
and you have what's probably netflix's
highest profile film of 2021 so far the
dig based on the 2007 novel by john
preston the dig stars ray fines and
carrie mulligan set in the late 1930s
mulligan plays a woman named edith
priddy who hires archaeologist basil
brown to excavate the land around her
property as brown gets further along in
his dig however he realizes that he may
be unearthing the discovery of a
lifetime the dig is one of those movies
that will have history hounds scrambling
once it's finished to learn more about
the true story surrounding it but
despite concerning itself with a
monumental and historic find this is
mostly a character-driven tale mulligan
and finds both give it their all and
many critics have lauded the film's
subdued pacing and moving drama
life is very fleeting
i've learned that
it has moments you should seize
it would be incredibly easy to just
scroll right past space sweepers but if
you're a fan of sci-fi action that would
be a huge mistake this adventure film
has been referred to by several outlets
as korea's first space blockbuster and
it features some great character work a
fun and compelling story and some
surprisingly strong visual effects space
sweepers takes place in a future where
earth is on the verge of being
uninhabitable select wealthy individuals
are given a chance to live on a space
station but most of the human population
is stuck breathing in the poisoned air
of our atmosphere in this world the
eponymous space sweepers are essentially
sky pirates cruising through the
atmosphere to collect debris and sell it
for cash the movie's main cast is doing
just that when they discover something
extremely valuable both for the ruling
classes and the future of the planet
space weepers is a pretty wild ride and
has even been cited by some critics as a
decent substitute for star wars or
marvel movie who knows maybe they're
right
sometimes all you want is a little
rom-com convenience to pick you up to
all the boys always in forever is the
third film in the franchise and it'll
give you exactly that namely high school
drama blown up to the nth degree with
everything working out and wrapping up
nicely in the end based on the book
trilogy by jenny han always and forever
is a fitting and fun conclusion to the
all the boys saga the trilogy follows
laura jean high schooler who writes
letters to boys she has a crush on and
then locks the notes in her closet one
day those letters get sent out as a
prank and laura jean has to navigate
some very awkward situations when the
recipients come asking about them more
specifically always in forever finds
laura and her boyfriend preparing for
college and the possibility of having to
navigate a long distance relationship
sure it's silly but it's remarkably well
acted and pretty darn charming for a
high school rom-com if you're not really
a fan of romantic comedies let your
guard down a bit and give it a whirl
it's way better than you think
what's that idris elba riding a horse
soul
and hey turns out there's a whole movie
centered on the premise concrete cowboy
on top of being a really impressive
piece of character drama it's also based
on a real-life group the fletcher street
urban writing club is made up of inner
city cowboys who still operate in
downtown philadelphia concrete cowboy is
about a young man named cole who moves
to philadelphia to hopefully set his
life straight through his estranged
father played by elba cole becomes
enamored with the urban cowboy lifestyle
but trouble tends to follow him around
it all comes to a head when some of
cole's friends cross paths with a local
drug dealer caleb mclaughlin and elba
give great performances here and their
supporting cast also put on a good show
the big draw of concrete cowboy however
is a fascinating culture of the writers
and naturally lots of lovely shots of
beautiful horses
apparently a fear of people stuck in
small spaces struggling to survive
gained some traction during the pandemic
who would have guessed it and if you're
a fan of foreign films and you'll find
oxygen to be a breathtaking thriller one
that'll keep you guessing right up until
the end credits this french language
film stars melanie laurent as a woman
who wakes up inside a cryogenic sleep
chamber because her oxygen is running
dangerously low she has no memory of
what she's doing there and is forced to
fix things before the air runs out
it doesn't help that her ai assistant
isn't giving her the answers she needs
either worse still her near total
isolation and oxygen deprivation lead
her to question everything she's
experiencing in the first place oxygen
is directed by horror regular alexandra
ajah who recently held the surprisingly
entertaining crawl so it's got some
bonafides attached to it it's also
carried almost entirely by laurent's
impressive performance and despite that
hugely stressful premise the central
mystery is actually a whole lot of fun
when a movie boasts a cast like stowaway
it's hard not to take notice stowaway is
a thriller that follows a small team of
scientists headed to mars tony collette
plays the captain in the mission anna
kendrick the medical officer and daniel
day kim a biologist researching ways to
bring plant life to the red planet of
course the title of the movie should tip
you off that there's someone else
involved someone who isn't supposed to
be there what follows is a
claustrophobic and intense look at how
far these people will go to keep
everyone safe on an already dangerous
trip one of the most interesting choices
stowaway makes is not letting the
audience hear any of the communications
the team has outside of one another i
still need this crew to be able to
perform critical tasks
no they cannot do that if they are
devastated by guilt
it all feels incredibly intimate as any
chatter with mission control is entirely
one-sided you want to know what they're
saying down there but you're stuck on
the ship with the characters instead it
really doesn't get much more intense
than this
if you only stick to the english
language section of netflix you're going
to miss out on some really great titles
a perfect example is skater girl a film
about a young girl from a rural
community in india falling in love with
skateboarding skater girl is a classic
fish out of water sports movie you know
the drill a teenager is introduced to
some new activity with wide-eyed
amazement overcomes difficulties and
prejudices to learn it and eventually
begins inspiring others with their
passion but a few other aspects of
skater girl help it stand out from the
pack the first is the impressive casting
there aren't a lot of recognizable
actors here unless you regularly watch
hindi language films but everyone puts
on a great performance most notably the
lead rachel sanchita gupta in her first
ever professional role and then there's
the cinematography everything about
skater girl is beautiful to look at and
the skateboarding scenes are nothing
less than stunning the whole movie feels
full of life and kinetic energy making
it that much easier to lose yourself in
its story
it seems unlikely you missed army of the
dead as netflix put a whole lot of hype
behind its release
even still this is one of their most
ambitious original titles in quite some
time and it takes a lot of boxes for a
lot of people after all it's a zombie
heist movie with an impressive ensemble
cast written and directed by zack snyder
and if that caught your attention then
this one is probably right up your alley
dave bautista stars as a former special
ops soldier who's tasked with taking a
team into las vegas to steal millions of
dollars from a casino vault oh and vegas
has been barricaded to contain a zombie
outbreak inside the city oh and nuke is
going to be dropped on it in a few days
army of the dead is a fun matchup of one
last job heist and zombie horror and a
truly motley crew of international stars
joins batista on his mission
i'm not trying to be the bad guy we
should be incentivized
to let him die
all in all this makes for a lot of fun a
ton of slow-mo and even more crazy
violence this is zack snyder at his
snyderist
some of the best horror movies explore
the lengths to which people will go in
order to protect the people they love
and blood red sky is an excellent
example of this this brutal and gory
creature feature has a surprising amount
of heart packed in there considering all
that violence and it's far more fun than
the plot might lead you to believe here
are the basics a woman named naja and
her son are on an overnight flight and
she's clearly suffering and trying to
hide it from it but when a group of
terrorists hijack the plane and kill the
flight crew they get much more than they
bargained for nadja is unable to keep
her inner beast at bay and she
transforms into a savage vampire that
begins picking off the many threats to
her son's life more than anything the
movie's creature design and inventive
kills are a blast to watch fans of more
brutal feral vampire flakes are sure to
enjoy this one and horror lovers in
general will almost certainly get a kick
out of it too
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you